i've gotten a lot better at guessing
what product these woke commercials are
selling okay i'm still not i'm still not
doing great because these these
companies are really just selling a
radical ideology and the product is
secondary but last time we tried this i
think i was batting a little bit better
than i than i have been in the past all
right over four never mind
so we've got four more woke commercials
my producers have pulled them you've all
sent them in
let's see how i do
maybe a like a
cell company like a telecom company
[Music]
yeah that's what i'm gonna say i'm gonna
say it's like a telecom company
like it's not just a cell phone it's
like a
service provider
[Music]
oh no
[Music]
oh no
everyone works hard for a reason
working together we can help you prepare
financially for when two becomes three
wells
together we'll go far
wow man that that took you on a journey
because you the woke thing at first is
the sign language right and it's this
idea that you know
ableism erases people with these
disabilities and so we're going to use
sign language and okay but you know that
this that that's just the ideology parts
you're like okay i don't know maybe the
product though is like a cell phone or a
computer or something to communicate
right okay that starts to make sense and
then at a left field you get the
lesbians and you say but actually it's
ableism and lesbians and that's why you
should choose our bank it's so dense
every single image has so many things
going on you're like man i can't keep up
that's too much at the end you got to
give me some clues on the way i
completely blew that one
what's up next
cooper
serial you would your father you would
imagine no no i
am your father
where is the mother the worst fader ever
how about you be chewbacca
like a
breakfast company real life
soup oh i guess
ah man i actually was like i
ah i want partial credit because it
looked like cereal so i did and there
obviously the ideology they're selling
is the two dads thing but i did think i
was like the only thing even resembling
a product there are two products in here
and it's star wars and what i thought
was cereal so i got no breakfast you
know but i guess it was soup it's like
star wars soup do i get partial credit
no no i don't okay i'm gonna appeal that
after this video is done let's go on to
number three
when were you first considered a family
[Music]
when you fell in love no
when you got married yes
when you had kids
that would continue the family when did
you first fight to be considered a
family
[Music]
when you fell in love
when you got married well
oh wait that was
no that was just a man and a woman that
wasn't two yeah that you can be a family
they're saying though it's like
interracial okay tylenol
tylenol
tylenol well they're really slick in
here too because they're like hey when
when did you become a family when you
fell in love it's like no no one no
you're you and your middle school
girlfriend are not a family right you're
just like dating when you got married
yes obviously that's when you become a
family what about when you had kids well
you're growing the family but no you
become a family when you leave your
father and mother and cling to one
another and take a vow before god and
get married
well when did you have to fight to be a
family like okay it's going to be some
gay thing right it's going to be well
because marriage for all of human
history every single place on earth
meant one thing and it had to do with
sexual difference and then five minutes
ago we decided it has nothing to do with
that whatsoever so see that's the grave
injustice but then they're so sneaky
because instead they they kind of allude
to the gay thing but then they they push
the like interracial marriage thing
which for all of human history
everywhere different peoples have got
have intermarried and sometimes there
are restrictions on that and for a
period in american history there were
some restrictions on that but throughout
the history of marriage peoples have
intermarried okay it's in the bible it's
in
lots of other texts and lots of other
histories they're doing that to suggest
that racial difference is the same thing
as sexual differences gays are the new
blacks but it's obviously not sexual
difference is far more fundamental to
human nature tylenol
tylenol
where did that come from tylenol okay do
i get one more there are two of them
you're gonna give me two thank you thank
you i get you're going to give me the
bonus all right so here's the last one
and then maybe i can redeem myself
don't worry they're going to love you oh
my god
[Music]
welcome to the family
thank you wow
[Music]
i wasn't even going to try to guess
how many gay guys do these companies
think there are billions
because like it's not i guess in their
mind it's like we're all just going out
trying to persecute the gay guys you
know but actually but it's like first of
all most people just don't really care
that much and you just think like well
men and women are different you know
marriage has a meaning but we're not
it's not like we're out like with
torches trying to persecute anybody but
so then to overcompensate for that these
people seem to think that like 90 of the
population is gay it's not it's like a
very small percentage of the population
and that has been true throughout
history and
etsy tylenol
get your tylenol and etsy for a year
okay that's all i'm over four yep
is there can i get one i i'm still upset
about the soup one because i think i
kind of deserve that but okay to redeem
my skill here my woke commercial
discerning skill
give me the bonus one
you know pride is about joy nickelodeon
connection but most importantly this
year and every year pride is about
visibility it's nick it's nickelodeon i
bet hey brent hey lady
guess what today with the help of the
family of brands we are going to
transform you into your most fabulous
self is the time of year where we get to
celebrate who we are
whatever you do
know that this pride is for you about
like your birthday did you celebrate
that on your birthday you are worthy and
you belong
on pride you get to celebrate who you
are as long as it's like a very specific
weird sexual thing
this is just a team yes who you are a
victorian woman june 4th as procter
gamble teams up with i heart radio for
can't cancel pride
die hard radio and proctoring gamble
it's always fracturing campbell it's
like the wokest thing i thought it was
nickelodeon because what i thought that
drag queen was on nickelodeon
he was yeah okay
wow oh for five do we even have to put
this on youtube i am so embarrassed i
don't know
i guess i'm just out of practice please
send in your vote commercials please for
for my masochism maybe that's my
sexual
kink i'm a masochist that's the only way
to explain why i still watch these
videos please send them in we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]